in five oh that's one you stupid ass in
five four three three two one hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
genius brain podcast
I am your co-host David so with the very
talent Doge itsuka wha
err oh no you know what crap here the
last video that I saw there was somebody
that wrote oh when I saw him I
automatically knew he was Japanese no
you [ __ ] did it dude no one knew
there wasn't
if that was true there was there wasn't
a single comment in six or seven years
that said Japanese once I know no one
knew yeah and there was no new now
everybody already knew that they was
they always knew always if that was the
case in those eight or whatever six or
eight years somebody would have wrote
Joe as Japanese not a single comment
said that do you know the only people
that knew were Japanese people that or
people that study Japanese and could
read my tattoo that was the only tell oh
really yeah then I knew that they you
know it's cuz obviously that's a it's a
Japanese name on my chest so but the
kanji looks like Chinese to me so I just
it does but it doesn't make sense in
Chinese that's why they'll be like what
is that that's a Japanese name Joe I'm
not Joe Bart has a has a Japanese tattoo
on his legs here right yeah but it's all
[ __ ] up they mean it means like scared
of everybody or something like that as
it's he meant to do fear no one
uh-huh and my mom saw that dude like and
she was like why is he afraid of people
and I'm like what do you mean he goes
that tattoo on his leg is wrong
now how did you get the translation who
did you get it from he went to he went
on Google Translate or some [ __ ] and the
funny thing is Bart had Japanese friends
but they're all like fifth sixth
generation that can't even speak and
they were like it's cool yeah Bart's
probably more Japanese and they are tiny
then he's still more Japanese did the
[ __ ] white person mistake did yeah
literally yeah I mean it's just it's
opposite right so if you wanted fear no
one
uh-huh but in you know like any Asian
languages it's usually like the way that
the sentence structure is its opposite
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so if when
it's just
out of order and it doesn't make ohlike
like sense that's how it is in Korean -
or a lot of language is it the subject
matter is always different and how its
placed yeah so when he translated it it
was backwards yeah it was like afraid of
everybody instead of fear no one was
your mom cracking the [ __ ] up it was
like well it doesn't it doesn't really
mean afraid of nobody but it was just
mixed up it was mixed up so she was just
like it's all [ __ ] up she had no shame
and calling them out on it I was like
damn that will had a tattoo and I think
that's when you found out like he was
like [ __ ] it well you know how Bart's
all chill he's like [ __ ] it what okay
whatever nobody's gonna know the damn
difference yeah I didn't know I don't
know dope tattoo it's [ __ ] tight dude
well means I'm scared of everybody you
know a lot of people have been asking us
though about money stuff yeah man and
one of the biggest requests especially
because at the end of every video or
when it uploads I always ask a question
is what do you guys want to hear about
and the biggest reoccurring one right
now which surprisingly is a money
management yeah which it's interesting
because on Twitter I actually read this
thing which was this huge meme that was
going on where people were saying well
the older generation is calling us dumb
for not knowing how to do these things
well it's your [ __ ] fault for not
teaching us which I always felt a little
weird about like yes and no because if
you didn't know how to do something you
should have taken the initiative to go
and find out which and the older
generation don't know themselves yet
they didn't know themselves either and
there's still a handful of the older
generation that doesn't know yeah so you
can't blame an older generation in my
opinion for not knowing because they
don't know either
yeah they don't know the few that do
know they know because they you know
they figured it out themselves mm-hmm
right or and some people they don't
really know but they just pretend well
they're just like they're just super
duper cheap mmm that's not real wealth
oh that's right you know like it's like
it's like that's like the like I guess
the immigrant way of doing things right
like it's all cash you save save save
save you don't do anything on credit and
then like you don't but you that's no
way to live either cuz like you don't
you live like like you're in poverty
there was that article where they I
think it was a couple that retired by
the time they're in their mid-30s is
because they learned how to save
properly
but they kind of did it in a way that I
wouldn't live so for example yeah it
would like say that well we save
toothpaste by rolling it up and then
cutting out inches out of it and
scraping it out it's like yeah I don't
know about living like that though you
know there um there is a movement going
on right now [ __ ] I forgot the name of
it man I think hold on I got it I got it
I got a research this I think it's
called chalk
I think it's called chalk or some [ __ ]
but but yeah you could I mean go on I
gotta find this but but this is a big
thing that's happening right now yeah
but this whole like I think it's great
that a younger generation really does
take the time to think about their
finances because when I was younger I
didn't think about my finances like that
like I didn't think about trying to make
my money either one stretch out or think
about putting into places where it could
make me money yeah it wasn't something
that I was thinking about the age of 18
19 20 or maybe even when I was 25 or 26
hmm so it'sit's kind of fascinating that
a younger generation now is actually
curious about that I just think it's
it's weird that I guess you're you're
kind of blaming an older generation for
not teaching you when that older
generation didn't know either so whoever
is out there that's in like that's older
than you they're saying oh you're dumb
for not knowing well they might just be
the few people that figured it out but I
think people in our generation which
were Millennials - we didn't know we had
to figure out for ourselves yeah which
was hard because you know my parents
didn't know much either they just
thought about saving money saving money
saving money you know they're the
they're the immigrant story right yeah
come here open up a shop and just save
save save yeah and don't do anything on
credit exactly right but they also
didn't live like a very fulfilling life
like we did mm-hmm
cuz like yeah they got to travel and
things like that but like not to the
extent of how we're living yeah and it's
hard to just because I think our parents
being immigrants they kind of they were
already at a disadvantage because a lot
of other parents if you compared to them
that lived in this country they had
access to knowledge that they didn't
have Yeah right so for us when we were
trying to figure out how to go to
college we had to figure that ourself
right
our parents only knew a get these good
grades and you get into a college well
guess what about scholarships what about
grants we had to figure that out
and that's but that's
why we became so self-sufficient hmm
because well okay this is what the
movement is called it's called fire
financial independence early retirement
if I are yeah oh this is what this
entire early
financial independence retire retire
early fi re fire that's the wave that
people are on right now well you know
what this community's pretty dope
because there's people that are like 70
or 60 years old but they did this early
like like you know they're like man we
did this like in our 30s so there's a
lot of people like going back to your
story of like yeah they're 25 and then
they just [ __ ] live as if they're
like in poverty yeah and then they just
put all their money into stocks and all
this stuff and then they just retire and
then they they basically retire like at
30 something but then they continue they
just do hobbies so they end up making
more money yeah but they don't have to
worry about where their income comes
from in all that [ __ ] oh so basically
the game plan is this is what they do it
usually you know these people have
decent incomes like they're they're
professionals they're making like 80
grand but there are people that do it as
like laborers or like people that are
like blue-collar workers that are making
40 grand a year or whatever right but
the whole point is to keep your base
income as low as possible
I mean basic spending zone all you're
worrying about is like where you sleep
what you eat you know and then you just
you're making you try to make money but
you try to like live on like 20% of that
ocean an 80% of that you just invest
invest invest right and then when you
get when you get to a certain point of
your investment um you take out like 4%
out of your stocks now I don't want to
like bore people because it gets kind of
complicated but it's mathematically
proven that if you only take out four
percent of your investment every year
you'll be ok huh so you
the stocks even when it goes down or or
whatever it'll be fine oh [ __ ] yeah
so then be and in that 4% is supposed to
take care of their monthly expenses so
it's really living minimally and then
kind of very minimal yeah yeah but
that's just like for the bare minimums
right so then now since they have all
this time freedom and all that [ __ ] and
then like they end up stopped working
and their stocks are just paying their
base with that free time all these
people these people do things that they
wanted to do like oh like they wanted to
get into carpentry so then they start
doing custom wood [ __ ] for people yeah
or like they with their free time they
learn another language and then they
start translating books or like they do
other activities without the burden of I
need to make money I need to make money
to to feed my kids to do this to do that
well that was the that's that's kind of
interesting because that's that's my
goal right yeah so when I tell people
this um when I say to somebody you know
I want to retire early and the first
thing that somebody always asks is goes
they go well what are you gonna do with
all that free time if you retire early
you're not gonna be able to do anything
like you're gonna be bored out of your
mind
yeah and my thing is well that just
means that you only see yourself as a
career person and that's the whole
breadth of your life well cuz people
don't know what retirement is right like
when you think of retirement you think
after 65 yeah and you're just sitting on
your ass chilling because that's what
retirement is like for most people yeah
when you look at retirement you see
grandpa and grandma are like I'm going
on you know and then they're just
chillin they're going play bingo they're
going to Vegas they're going on cruises
they're bored yeah but that's not what
real retirement is to me retirement is
like not having to work for the sake of
paying your bills anymore
yeah and that's that's kind of what I
wanted to just tell people and I don't
think people really understood that they
go well if you're not working you're
bored I'm like I'm still going to be
working but I'm going to be working on
the things that don't require me to work
just to pay the day-to-day stuff yeah
right so because a lot of the times when
we work it's simply so we could survive
because we need to keep the lights on we
need to pay for food but if that's
eliminated and you're refining
actually retired from that your work can
be literally everything like my I want
to learn I want to constantly learn I
want to do a lot of things who knows
what I'm gonna do with my time but I'd
always want to fill up your time with
hobbies exactly I don't there are so
many things that I want to do I dare to
you I'm gonna die before I get to do
them yeah for sure you know yes it's
just not possible to me the way I see
money is like choice choices hmm so a
lot of people be like why do you need so
much money like all this stuff and I
used to think like that too so I know
exactly where they're coming from I used
to think money was like so the root of
all evil you know people are so greedy
if we didn't have so much like people
that need money or want money so badly
the world would be a better place but I
realized money is just choice it's like
you could do good with it you could do
bad with it you just have more options
when you have it it's like a cheat code
in a game exactly so like you can use it
for good and the first time I realize I
needed money was when my cousin went
bankrupt and then I had 30 grand saved
up and then I gave it to them and I was
like dude if I didn't have this 30 grand
where would they get it from
yeah and yes I worked hard for it but
it's like also something that's like
this what money is is it's it's a it's
protection it's it's safety it's like
all that [ __ ] you know it's not just
because before that like I'm like I
don't want a new car like I don't want
new things like I don't care I could I
could live on nothing mm-hmm so I just
didn't get the point of it until an
emergency happened and like you don't
want to wait till emergencies and things
happen to where you're like oh [ __ ] and
then I started thinking about other
things like if I want a family
do I want to raise my kids in that
situation like that I grew up in know I
want the best for them because I think
about my past and I'm like well I went
to a shitty school system if my parents
had money maybe it would have been way
different you know yeah it's it's
interesting because that's that's
actually one of the things that I think
financially if if people were to think
about financial stability that's
that at a young age that a lot of people
don't think about so a lot of the times
when people think about their expenses
they they don't think about the
incidentals right for example for you
having that money and being able to give
it out to your family when they needed
it yeah and so when people do their
finances they don't think about that
part they just go okay I'm making $5,000
a month let's just say that's your
salary which is a decent it's great
salary $5,000 a month they go cool I'm
gonna get this place the rent is about
two grand a month foods gonna cost me
about five hundred and I'll have a car
it's about another 500 they go I got
$2,000 to play with you actually don't
have $2,000 you don't cuz you're not
thinking about the bills the car braking
the car breaking down the oil that needs
to be changed you know that other time
when you have to when you're gonna spot
somebody for some money the other times
when you want to buy shoes clothes
movies you're going out and doing all
this stuff and next thing you know you
realize that that $5,000 is gone it's
gone so people don't really think about
they think about their bare minimum and
they only leave this small cushion for
the stuff that they think that they're
gonna need we'll take that number and
double it because that's really what
it's going to cost and I think my goal
has always been to live on 10% of my
income hmm that's that's always been my
goal and I lived that for four or five
years well I [ __ ] up for like the last
two years though I think we all [ __ ]
up for the last two years man one of the
things that we went through recently was
you know during the time when number one
YouTube was very profitable
yeah and specifically for us we put all
of our time onto this space and for us
it was about gaining like financial
stability and just having a surplus of
money yeah for whatever reason that is
and so for for me specifically I was
spending the right amount for the money
that I was making at the time and what I
didn't realize that when I decided to do
a more artistic route and decided to say
hey you know what maybe I don't need
this money
yeah I didn't make an adjustment and
change the way that I was spending yeah
and so it was just overspending and I
would I had the advice that I'm giving I
was having those problems yeah well I
mean we all had a problem with scaling
yeah right like it's like we blew up
really quick so did our habits
mm-hm and then it was like oh wait a
minute
you know if we're gonna produce less
content or whatever then we also have to
make sure we balance our checkbook
checks the same way yeah I think a lot
of people have this problem like on a
smaller scale like working a
nine-to-five job like you said you make
5 grand then you're spending that five
grand all of it you're not putting
anything to the side yeah and we all had
jobs we all knew what what that's like
but it's like it's like the worst way to
do anything because you'll never save
and then and then the magic credit card
comes along ah that's right you go I got
a job I'll pay that [ __ ] later yep zero
percent down [ __ ] Z I mean 0% APR what
does that mean you don't have to you
know they're not gonna put interest on
it and awesome but when that 12 month
promotional or like whatever comes along
they're like they forget and then it's
like it starts adding and adding and
adding you wanna help me realize how
much money I was spending on stupid [ __ ]
like one of the biggest things that I
spend on the most is food I love trying
out new food no matter what the cost is
I'm buying it I'm eating it yeah and so
there was a point in doing pretty well I
just stopped looking at that number sign
on the men came here you know I want
that steak I want that fries I want that
scrimp I don't give a foot give it to me
and so what was happening was what
helped me realize how much I was
spending was when I started stopped
using I stopped using this credit card
and I actually sorted using cash and
then if you have like this wad of cash
right and you go this is what I'm gonna
spend on food this month and then you
really start to see how much money
you're using because that physically it
starts to go away like this
so let's say if I gave myself a $600 a
month budget to go out to eat yeah and
then I'm like cool I'm still gonna keep
up the same habits well guess what I
won't because sometimes I would have
spent like $100 on a meal just because I
wanted to try everything on the menu
just for the [ __ ] of it well 100 bucks
that's oh that's a fat chunk of that
[ __ ] yeah and that's only one day out
of the 30 days out the month - it's
shocking yeah when you actually see the
money go away it's it's crazy cuz this
whole thing about finance and money
management and all that [ __ ] like
there's a lot of information out there
yeah and it can get really overwhelming
really really overwhelming but I like to
keep
very simple and then you know I tell
people first and foremost what you want
to do is calculate your bare necessities
what that means is like how much is your
rent if you don't have to pay rent
awesome how much is your car payments
how much are the things that you
absolutely need to pay or else you're
gonna die for so for an adult what would
that be that would be what rent rent
phone car if you're in LA like if your
New York you don't need that
transportation but you should budget
like ticket costs and whatever yeah
obviously food that's the most flexible
thing but in for young people they spend
the most on food mm-hmm and so it's car
food car food room hygiene considered
phone phone phone iPhone like uh yeah
your your monthly phone yeah and um car
insurance but that's included in the
cars when you calculate your car you're
thinking car payments yeah your how much
you spend on gas your insurance all that
[ __ ] is your monthly for that health
insurance if you pay for that
that's your bare necessities other than
that like you don't need anything mm-hmm
so that's what I calculate and then I'd
say try to make that fifty percent of
your income no [ __ ] that's hard yeah
that is very hard but if you're making
like a thousand dollars a month and
you're living at home you can do that
for five hundred bucks yeah
and if you're not you need to get out of
spending a thousand dollars for your
[ __ ] luxury car when you're only
making two thousand dollars it's hard
because when it comes to finances and
people think about bare necessities they
maybe they add stuff that shouldn't be
in there yeah well obviously I gotta buy
some clothes no you don't that's not a
bare necessity you [ __ ] yeah
people there's this is not a wavering
definition of what bare necessities is
man when me and bar was coming up he had
these t-shirts that were rich that he
got from a promo it was a free giveaway
he had five of the same t-shirts that he
washed it was a ghost of the abyss movie
okay
and and this is the beginning of JKD
like I would go to the [ __ ] swap meet
and buy t-shirts like you don't need to
be you you really don't you go to the
thrift shop you don't need that many
clothes
yeah you really don't know you probably
have enough clothes right now to last
you a whole [ __ ] year but people will
add that [ __ ] and say yeah I need it
yeah no you don't it's it's a it's it's
it's just being young mm-hmm and I think
that's what people have to realize so
within that first advice is to really
understand what your bare necessities
are you know if you like I said it's not
something that wavers from definition to
definition you can't add clothes because
you say well clothes make me happy
that's not we're not talking about
emotions yeah we're just talking about
facts here
your emotional attachment to clothing
and earrings don't [ __ ] it back yes
survival first and foremost what do you
need to survive mm-hmm shelter looks
kisses yeah that's it like a like if you
were here just imagine I tell everybody
imagine this is this is a yeren
immigrant you don't even know English
this is a new country you don't know
anybody here all you need to do is
survive what would you do know you you
know and a lot of people got it [ __ ]
mixed up like a lot of people go how
much like how do you make more money how
do you make more money like usually it's
not the case that you need to make more
money it's how do you control your
spending is the case because there's
guys out there that make like thirty
thousand a year but they live on 12000 M
they live on very little right so they
save a lot of money like you know versus
like like they're almost self saving
like 20 grand and in like there's guys
out there that are like making 80 grand
but then they spend 90 grand mm-hmm so
it just doesn't matter how much you make
if you don't know how to manage and
control your spending
you're [ __ ] so for example my roommate
he's a pharmacist right and and he was
so [ __ ] frugal like he didn't even
buy a bed he lived in a he slept on a
freakin sleeping bag like you
hello refugee but he was so smart though
because he basically put a lot of his
money into investments and then
he was he had like $200,000 in debt
right but all he told me this is what
happens to a lot of his pharmacy buddies
that graduate yeah they graduate with
200,000 in debt but it's like this poor
college student that all of a sudden
starts making money right so my buddy
was making $130,000 a year so yeah as a
pharmacist that's really good so so
let's say you all of a sudden come
you're a college student you all of a
sudden come into all this money and
you're like [ __ ] I'm gonna have money
all day every day I have a good stable
job whatever so what do they do they buy
that luxury car cuz they gotta be a
pharmacist now they got they buy these
nice suits to go to these like meetings
to or whatever they have to live that
life right like you were this poor
college student now you got all this
money you got to live that life but now
they're in debt because $200,000 down
the drain or they have to owe to to to
the [ __ ] loans and [ __ ]
they buy a freaking luxury car let's say
$80,000 right and then all these nice
clothes whatever fancy food whatever and
then they're gonna get married in the
next couple years mm-hmm
and then they're gonna pay for like a
$70,000 wedding you know already we
racked up close to $300,000 and then you
know what's gonna come after that
wedding right house you know and in
living in LA at least $700,000 and they
need to put down what 200,000 but they
don't got that money so what do they do
they do the zero to five percent down
yeah yeah which is high-ass monthly
payments but they can but they can do it
because they'll be like well you know
especially if both of them are
pharmacists they'll be like [ __ ] it like
we we make so much on paper but then
they're stuck if they want to change
that job they want to leave that life
they can't they're stuck they're stuck
and then they're paying more than
they're making so you could have a
household income of to $300,000 but
there's but they're so in debt that
they're just
and I'm like that is no way to live man
that's hard because I think living
minimal even though there is a new wave
of that it's hard for people because
once again that definition of minimal
seems to change from person to person
yeah for me specifically learning how to
really figure out what's important help
me out with my finances a lot too so you
know what it's hard because there are
gonna be a lot of kids out there that
probably didn't grow up with a lot of
stuff yeah and then when you finally
have a job that pays you well you're
gonna want to fulfill your childhood
dreams that's like us yeah you know how
many guns I bought I calculated the
other day about forty thousand dollars
worth of guns and equipment god damn
dude no joke
thank God I could resell them for the
same price if I need to yo I'm telling
you even for me I got rid of a lot of my
shoes for me was like Jordans and Nikes
whatever the [ __ ] it was and I had over
a hundred pair of shoes oh my god god I
got [ __ ] two feet what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do with that [ __ ] for a guy that
wore basketballs and basketball shorts
and a t-shirt most of the time and I and
I just kept on trying to fulfill like
fill this hole this this this this want
and this journey that I had as a kid as
an adult because now I have play money
yeah that at the end of the day I was
left with the hundred pairs of shoes
yeah no place to put him and no feet to
put him on so I sold that [ __ ] and now
I'm left without thirty thirty left and
I'm still trying to get rid of half of
that I mean if if you're fulfilling a
childhood dream or something though go
up by all means do it like just but do
it responsibly man like by like one shoe
a year or something like that you know
add to your collection once a year or
something I always say like you can do
whatever you want as long as you're a
responsible with your money yeah mind
you if those shoes at the time when I
bought those shoes yeah I was making a
decent amount of money and I had no
expensive so whatsoever aside from like
a small place that I was paying yeah I
didn't buy a car or anything else so all
I was buying with shoes and clothes or
whatever and so financially it was still
okay for me but now when I look back on
it I just think of okay and it goes back
to where people were you know the fire
people that money they would have used
that to invest it into the future so
they don't have to work
which now is a big goal of mine so if I
had done that six years ago oh yeah you
would have been retired I mean both of
us would have been retired but we
decided to do some risky investments
yeah because the payoff is just better
so my personal style is is doing risky
things when I'm young and the older I
get the more safer my investments are
yeah what these guys are doing is
they're just putting money into safe
things from the start yeah so they might
not make seven figures but let's say
they'll make $40,000 a year just on
their investments you know and that's
that's not what they're living on 40 so
they live a nice like middle-class
lifestyle especially if with because
they move out of state too so a lot of
these guys they'll move out of state and
and because they can achieve that
lifestyle so if you buy a house in
Tennessee or whatever man you're getting
a 3-bedroom home for like $60,000 yeah
okay so if you think about it that way
you know they make that money stretch
they make that money in San Francisco LA
New York or whatever and then you move
out to like the countryside or whatever
and then you know it's way different out
there so if we could give the first
advice if we summed it up the first
thing would be to really manage your
finances in spending yep what would be
the second thing the second thing was
would be try to increase your income hmm
so whether that be in your own type of
field of work look for side hustles like
driving for uber you know you can teach
classes if you if you know another
language or whatever you can do that
online just try to figure out small
little gigs here and there my thing was
eBay mmm yeah like I was working at a
regular like nine-to-five warehouse
place doing shipping and [ __ ] like that
you me and my buddies we started at eBay
business what did you sell well first we
started selling things out of our
closets and then we went to yard sales
and we bought items and then sell it on
eBay for higher prices and then
we ran out of that and we're like it's
inconsistent because sometimes we'll do
like five yard sales and we don't find
anything worth while buying so we
learned about like reselling getting a
whole sellers license army retailers
license and going to whole sellers and
we bought like diecast cars airsoft guns
car parts all kinds of [ __ ] and we sold
it on eBay oh yeah and that's when I got
my first like knowledge of business
really yeah and I read like um Rich Dad
Poor Dad that got me into the whole
world of like financial education cash
flow quadrant [ __ ] like that
I recommend books you know people gotta
read like unfortunately finance is one
of those things it's not that easy it's
like it's hard goodness it's like
working out right there's a lot of
information but it can be fun I just
know that it gets overwhelming cuz
there's so much information out there
but if you do baby steps like this is I
think this is way more fun than any
video game it's real life yeah cuz like
the points is money and when you get the
points you can use it and trade it in
for good [ __ ]
yeah and it's it's you know when people
try to increase their income I always
hear a lot of people say like well I
don't have the time you know trust me
you do have the time unless you're funny
unless you're a mother with three kids
and no even that's not an excuse because
you know why like so my friend's mom she
was a she was like a teller at a bank
right she has three kids and at the time
she realized she wanted to get into
education so she decided to go back to
school while she was working at the bank
as a single mom raising her three kids
and then now she's a junior high teacher
making us you know they make good money
if you stay around for a while yeah so
she's like I think she makes 100 grand
just doing that there's time for the
things that you want in life and yeah I
think that's what people are confusing
right they go well I don't have time and
you know if when you say you don't have
time with what you're really saying some
and sometimes I'm not saying this this
is for all cases yeah
but from people who are relative
well laughs and what I mean by that
they're not in poverty yeah right what
do you mean is that it's tiring it's
really really tiring yeah and that's
just a sacrifice that you have to make
you know for us to arguably we could
just do YouTube focus on that 100% and
try to make that income there but
there's a reason why we invest into
these businesses not only because it's a
passion of ours because we really do
enjoy the stuff that we create but we
have to think about what we're gonna do
with this money to make it stretch mm-hm
and also have fun with it at the same
time because that's just how our
personalities are yeah but if I just
told myself every day you know what I'm
too busy I'm too tired and instead of
taking this time to really develop and
push the things that I need for the
future goal that I have which is retire
early then yeah I could use that time to
sleep a little extra I'm gonna use that
time to do more ty seven times a week
instead of just three I could do that to
start painting I could use that to
[ __ ] find out how I could fart and
make music out of my [ __ ] if I wanted
to but I'm not gonna do that right
because I do have a future goal so a lot
of the times when people say I don't
have time to do this it usually means I
don't have time because it's exhausting
yeah I think they don't know where to
start
yeah so and I also think that people
don't know what hard work looks like and
I sound like a geezer when I say this
but like it's true cuz I was like that -
mm-hmm you know like when you're not
exposed to the world you just don't know
what you're capable of and then and then
you get discouraged really fast and easy
and it seems like everyone else has it
figured out except for you so I I have a
lot of like compassion for people that
that feel overwhelmed but I would say
that the best advice that I can give is
to try and listen to success stories
yeah cuz you'll hear about people that
were in worse situations than you who
made it and it gives when I hear stories
like that it gives me hope like just
just over the weekend you know I was at
karate camp and then one of the guys
he's a new member he's a Nigerian
immigrant so he's been in the States
since 2014 he's a doctor back at home
thus [ __ ] recent very recent yeah so
I mean he has a thick accent and
everything and so he was he was an act
a doctor back at home in in Africa he
was practicing medicine and all that
stuff right and I and I was asking him
like Oh like why by the state's knee
goes why not he's like it's awesome here
and then so I was like so I can do
karate yeah it sounds like you want to
be a dots I was like so are you gonna go
back and work as a doctor and you know
his license doesn't work here yeah it
doesn't work though so he has to do it
all from scratch and I was like hold up
so you went to college there University
Medical School you did all that stuff
you have to redo that here and he's like
yeah him he goes he has to take this
test it's not the MCAT it's another one
yeah because he says that he's not a
student anymore so he just has to take a
test and do a residency so basically for
the next like six years this guy is
gonna be working like a regular job and
then he's gonna be doing a residency
like a student again she's he has to do
it all over and then he can start
practicing medicine and it's it's just
he says it's just paper
like it's just difference in a little
bit of paperwork and the method is a
little bit different but he says like
just do it all over yeah and it's kind
of humiliating you know cuz it's like
you're a doctor already and then you
have to go back to being a student again
mhm but it blew my mind because that's
it's just blows my mind every time I
meet immigrants right their work I think
what they have to go through what they
do it's just totally on a different
level yeah and when we hear this from
our parents did they go you don't know
what hard work is when I look back on it
it kind of is true though it's true man
I don't have like anything close to my
parents energy yeah it's hard when I sew
just to put it in perspective for my
parents if I were to describe and I just
had this conversation with my mom the
other night when I was talking to her I
was driving home and it was she was just
kind of mentioning because we were
joking and laughing about this because
I'll tell my mom I was calling her a
psychopath because I was like what was I
was recollecting stories about how she
would blow the [ __ ] up I was like do you
remember this one time where I came out
in the middle middle at night and I
heard you and dad yelling at each other
and then right when I came outside I saw
you chuck a [ __ ] rice cooker at his
head Wow like a fully
loaded rice cooker and there's this part
with rice inside with rice it's wasteful
with rice inside and everything dude you
would have thought somebody was getting
married oh my god rice - no but it was
cooked rice and so there's this part of
our counter and I when I go back home up
I'll put it on Instagram but there's a
chunk that's missing because that's
where she chucked it at my dad and my
dad had to dodge that [ __ ] so I was we
were laughing about that [ __ ] I was like
what kind of psychopath are you why
would you do that and you know we were
laughing about but she was she explained
to me was you know and during that time
when you guys saw us fight so much it
wasn't because I didn't love your dad it
wasn't because you know things weren't
amazing between us it was because I was
stressed the [ __ ] out yeah uf she goes
you have to understand how stressed your
dad was - and that's probably really the
reason why you got yelled at so much
because you she goes first of all you
were a terrible child yes in perspective
you were insane yourself and on top of
having to deal with everything your dad
was having to deal with he had to deal
with you yeah and so she explained to me
she goes well think about it like this
your dad came to this country with
absolutely nothing he had literally $200
to his name he had to figure out how to
speak the language go through all the
finances somehow fine get your brother
you and me into the States while
bringing his mom and dad here to somehow
be financially stable to support them
support us and on top of that he was
running a full business he was working
as a mechanic part-time and then I was
cleaning up hotel rooms and then with
that your dad was still going to
seminary school try to get his trying to
be a pastor because he felt that he owed
something to God because he was allowed
to have a family in country so he made a
promise that God saying I will go to
seminary school and become a pastor
because you kept your promise and you
brought us here so on top of everything
that your dad had to deal with he had to
deal with me with my short temper
throwing rice cooker' at his head and
then he had to deal with you the kid
that never wanted to do anything that
anybody told him to do so she was like
so could you imagine that type of stress
and that's true though because when my
dad used to say like you don't know what
hard work is and now I understand yeah
oh and by the way too my dad was also a
deacon at a church and my mom cooked the
Sunday meals for the church yeah on
Saturday and Sunday for Korean school
and then Sunday for the for the meal
that we would had after so at Korean
churches typically after the sermon
they would make a meal for everybody to
eat mm-hmm and my mom was a part of that
kitchen staff and she would make the
sandwiches and the drinks for the Korean
school kids which I had to make with my
mom before I went to Korean school
mm-hmm yeah but I mean you you make a
good point because that is what you need
to paint to a lot of people to make them
understand the sacrifices that you need
to make in order for survival like you
got to understand where most of these
people are coming from to like if
they're young and they never had to be
responsible because their parents were
so hard-working mm-hmm
they don't know what it's like because
they've always been taken care of yeah
so it's really hard for someone that's
always been taken care of - all of a
sudden be responsible and like
hard-working on their own like I see
when kids grew up and they were forced
to do a lot of chores forced to work out
you know like or like from an early age
that we're just working or like as soon
as they were able to get a work permit
they started working they have a totally
different outlook on life and work ethic
than people that haven't had a job like
where there's a lot of people that's
never worked and after they graduate
college is when they first work because
there's a lot of Asian parents out there
that are like oh don't don't don't work
because we want you to focus a hundred
percent on studying but it damages them
because they just study and focus on
schoolwork they and then you know like
I'm pretty sure you had friends like
this to where they're like no
extracurricular activities no
relationships no work experience just
get good good grades 4.0 all the time
right and then they graduate and they
don't have any life experience and they
don't know what the [ __ ] to do that
happens a lot - in our community it's
scary because people don't put value in
social skills and social skills aren't
everything when you when you apply for a
job and I'm saying this by the way as an
employer as a person who employs people
most of the time when people hire you
they have your credentials by the way
they have that degree there's a million
people with the same degree same skills
same everything the only difference is
is your [ __ ] face in the way that you
speak and how you treat people exactly
yes so most people aren't even this this
by the way oh for actors too
this by the way when people hire people
on set - they're also thinking not only
about that role they're thinking do I
want to look at this [ __ ] person's
face every day when they're on set or
when I hire them yeah because at the end
of the day you're creating your work
community you come into this job
interview you have no social skills you
don't know how to speak to people you
don't know how to communicate you think
that you're a plus is any different from
somebody else is a plus this podcast was
brought to you by purple baby we're
talking about purple the company that
has created the best mattress I have
ever laid my heavenly heavenly body on
if you're a side sleeper if you're a
back sleeper it doesn't matter because
purple got the technology that's gonna
cradle your body which ever way that you
want
now this mattress my friends somehow has
managed to stay firm but soft at the
same time I know that sounds a little
weird but for those of you out there
that have been looking for the perfect
mattress this mattress can do it all I'm
a side sleeper I'm also a back sleeper
and it doesn't really matter because it
just it feels good either way so if you
guys didn't know about this mattress
company it was actually developed by a
rocket scientist so if you're worried
about the technology when it comes to
this product you don't have to be
worried at all I'm talking about rocket
scientists type of stuff so you get a
100 night risk-free trial if you're not
fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund it's also
backed by a ten year warranty and my
friends free shipping and returns we're
talking about the best customer service
in the game you are going to love purple
and right now my listeners will get a
free purple pillow with the purchase of
a mattress that's in addition to the
great free gifts they're offering
site-wide just text brain to eight four
- eight eight eight the only way to get
this free pillow is to text brain to
eight four - eight eight eight that's B
R a I n - eight four eight eight eight
messages and data rates may apply so if
you guys have slept on a crappy mattress
before and maybe you think that your
mattress is great try this out it's a
hundred nights for free and if you don't
like it
you can return it but I guarantee you if
you're gonna lay on it you're gonna love
it and you're not gonna want to return
it back because for just for me aside
from the side sleeping and the back
sleeping straight up I sweat a lot in my
sleep and this mattress somehow keeps
cool and I know that a lot of memory
foam that I slept on specifically for me
if I've had toppers before I sweat
through the whole damn thing
I make a sweat angel disgusting purple
mattress does not do that so give it a
go check it out and uh let me know what
you guys think shoutouts to purple baby
yeah I mean I blamed a school system man
because I feel like I was kind of like
total lie where I thought you know if I
graduated with a degree I get paid more
which no one gave up Aaron told that
yeah well yeah I mean that too but I
mean the psychology degree is worthless
it really is so education sociology
journalism like all these degrees are
[ __ ] worthless and I mean I'm a
couple of kids like oh [ __ ] what am i
doing and I'm saying this because I have
a psychology to do you need at least a
master's to have a decent job at least
right and that's that's the truth with a
lot of degrees now like back back in the
90s or whatever if you had physical
therapy bachelor's and then you take the
test you can already become a physical
therapist mm-hmm now you need a master's
now the competition is just getting
higher and higher you need a more higher
degree and in cost of college is higher
than higher too so like you have to
spend so much [ __ ] money all these
kids are like they're graduating with
like I don't know $50,000 in debt 30
thought there's like there's a debt
crisis right mhm
and then what are they doing like after
they graduate with [ __ ] dance studies
or you know like [ __ ] lesbian
feminism yeah whatever like that what
the [ __ ] can you do with that degree who
wants you with that degree what do you
aside from teaching like what and and
just just to just to that credit as well
if you are going to go into
a school right and then you are going to
just get a degree just to get a degree
don't go to a [ __ ] university are you
out of your mind are you out of your
[ __ ] mind do two years in Community
College and the transfer at a state
school or something exactly because the
education is gonna be the [ __ ] Saint
it is and that degree is gonna be the
same yep so at that point if you're
gonna just go for a site degree just to
get something so you can work a
communications job as as an entry-level
marketing intern somewhere do not go to
a university you are wasting a [ __ ] ton
of money now if you're gonna be like a
world-class researcher that's gonna find
some groundbreaking new [ __ ] in
psychology then by all means go to the
top schools that we need you yeah to
help with the mental health these days
you know we need people like that it all
depends like if you're just doing it to
please your parents or whatever but this
is a whole different story right what I
was trying to get with with about all
this stuff is that the degrees are not
what makes you a better worker yeah it's
it doesn't really mean [ __ ] and you're
not gonna be paid that much more just
because you have one depending on
industry of course but for the most part
it does not matter who you know matters
and when I go back to saying I wanted to
go back to the topic of side hustle
right so you can side hustle hustle
within your company and what I mean by
that is like let's say you're getting
paid for the job of data entry but I
every job that I went to I use that as
an opportunity to learn everything about
this company even if it doesn't if my
job description doesn't say that because
what I want to do is make this company
more efficient and better because of
what what because of my involvement yeah
if you see a lot of people don't
understand how to get a raise and how to
work within the company system and the
reason for that is school right the way
that school teaches you is here's what's
on the syllabus here's your tests here's
extra credit you do all these things
this is the points you will get in the
workplace that's not how it works
these you're creating a work soldier
is what you are right well and then you
shouldn't get we're not not that you
shouldn't but like most people they they
go all I've been a loyal you know
employee for 10 years I should get paid
more right like yes you should be
rewarded rewarded for your loyalty but
then there's there's a reason why some
new guy that comes in might get paid
more because that person is effective
they're adding value exactly and no one
knows how to add value that's what the
that's where the problem lies like I
understood very early on how to get into
a workplace for the bottom money like
for the cheapest amount as possible get
my foot in the door then I proved myself
within that company make them more money
and then I can argue a better price
point if I become irreplaceable to that
company I threatened to leave and then
they'll give me more money yeah they
need you you're an asset exactly or not
an employee anymore you're an actual
asset to the company a friend of ours
proved proved herself in a marketing
company recently and got herself a
six-figure income by doing that that's
[ __ ] crazy yeah because she she she
when she went in as like a like a data
entry type of person an intern and then
she came back studied the company did
this presentation and did all this work
and boom she secured herself as like a
high position that's amazing
and I think like that's what I mean by a
side hustle right like let's say you
don't ever do all these other things but
if you can not only prove your value but
bring money into the company now you
become irreplaceable and if you can't
and if they don't value you in that way
then that's a horrible company you leave
and you do that you do the same thing to
a company that will recognize that and
you will get paid more I hope a lot of
people can take this to heart too
because it's I don't want people to and
this once again is coming from an
employer and I've dealt with this issue
with a lot of employees where they they
believe that time spent equals I deserve
more money to a certain extent that's
true to a certain extent yet so what
happens is is they had this ID
of well I want to get paid more for
doing the same amount of work yeah you
know and for as an employer that
wouldn't make sense to me and there's
been points to where specifically I'm
one of my businesses we hired somebody
else to manage the store instead of this
person who has been here longer yeah and
in his mind he was jaded he goes well
how come I'm not and he never said it
but I could sense it you know when I
come in and I sense the motivation is
down or whatever and partially you know
we did talk about it before but I had to
talk to him again about it was he like
cuz I was here longer
how come this other person came in and
got it exactly and I gave him that
explanation I'd explained to him one
more time because his his work output
was terrible yeah and at this point now
he's about to get fired so but you know
it's all about second chances with me so
you know I talked to him I'll go
straight up I said you are upset because
this person got a raise and they took
the position that you wanted and you
didn't get it he goes oh no no no I'm
not I was like listen you're not gonna
get in trouble I just wanted you to be
honest so I could fix this problem he
goes yeah I just felt a little weird I
said well let me put this in perspective
how I see it as an employer is that you
have been here longer than her and she's
been working twice as hard as you and
not only she'd be working twice as hard
she has actually recommended things for
this company that has worked really well
yeah you have you came in here and
you're very fun to be around but you do
the bare minimum work yeah and at times
even with the bare minimum work you mess
up but people don't recognize that he
doesn't want to take he didn't want to
take responsibility for that yeah and
all he saw was time spent equalled more
money yeah but that's also immaturity
too yeah like like a lot of the
positions that we have are entry level
jobs for like college students and stuff
like that if you're still doing this as
an adult then you're completely [ __ ]
low IQ and eighty-eight it's it was it
is so weird because I guess for him it
was hard for me because he almost wanted
me to tend to his emotions but he didn't
want to listen to the facts that were
laid before him yeah so I can't sit here
and say well emotionally I should have
gave you the race it doesn't work that
way man you didn't add value yeah this
person did and this person did it in
literally half the time at you well they
also don't see what you do cuz we see
things from top bottom but we also know
what it feels like to be an employee
yeah so that that's the burden right is
like this is the age-old conflict like
you have business owners and then you
have employees and employees always
think that business owners are a bunch
of greedy fat guys that are smoking
their cigars with the [ __ ] monopoly
hats and [ __ ] and in and in the
employees are these like guys are being
taken advantage of that's kind of like
the stereotype right but then what they
fail to remember is that employers have
been employees just know the struggle
know what it feels like but once we get
the whole picture we realize a lot of
the misconceptions that we had as
employees and and I think the biggest
problem though is the expectations are
not set up right for employees when they
graduate college and the work things
aren't common sense yeah that should be
common sense so like you know if you're
at a workplace for like ten years plus
they go well I've been here for so long
I should get at least paid for like
loyalty or whatever which is true but
you also have to look at things as like
in the bigger picture right like if
you're doing the same thing a robot can
do a robot can can replace you
unfortunately but if you don't keep
sharpening your tools as a worker and
becoming better and faster or like
smarter if you keep doing the same exact
thing then there's really no reason why
people are gonna keep you and that's
just the unfortunate truth yeah right
like for example like you could be the
hardest-working pager in the world but
if a cell phone comes around
no one's gonna watch you anymore yeah so
that's the thing is like you got to
transform and better yourself and all
that stuff and unfortunately man I don't
think that they teach that in school
because in school it's so outdated so a
lot of people graduate without
understanding what they need to provide
and I think most people want to but
that's the problems that we run into
with new employees straight out of
college a lot of guys they want to do
good they
work hard they wanna contribute they
just don't know how so we're not seeing
eye to eye mm-hmm and I think that's one
of the struggles of like people
graduating and waking up to what the
world is really like one of the things
that I like that our partners do we own
a much of business and it's doing really
well one of the things that our partners
that are there for the day-to-day that
that really impresses me is that they
actually do leadership meetings yeah
where they teach a lot of the employees
how to be leaders and how to be managers
instead of just a day employee yeah and
that kind of stuff is really gonna set I
mean who knows that these people are
gonna stay with the company or not and
obviously they're they're going to go
off and do greater things but the but
the cool thing about that is that I
think that they're fulfilling a role
that traditional education didn't do for
them yeah or hasn't done for them we
really as business owners we have to
pick up where the education system
failed mm-hmm like we have to do the
other part man and it just sucks but
that's just the way it goes you know but
I think everyone has this thing where
like all Millennials are so entitled and
whatever I used to think that too and I
didn't realize I was a mother myself but
then it's because I got to learn fast so
now I should pay it forward and like
teach that to them like so like I was a
part of that group where I got my degree
I didn't feel like I feel like I got
cheated I was $30,000 in credit card
debt no one wanted me just because of
that degree like I thought if I got that
degree BAM I'm gonna get that job I
think everybody thinks this till till
this day I think everybody thinks that
cuz you're told everybody would a
college degree earn more income mmm
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] man yeah I mean
it's true statistically but just because
you get a degree you're not gonna get
[ __ ] nothing's gonna be handed to you
it's just a lot of personal
responsibility that it takes and I think
if you were to take something away from
this is that we're not saying that this
is easy we're actually saying it's very
very hard you just have to be prepared
for that type of workload and understand
what it's going to take
to have the things that you want yeah it
takes you to be an adult about it and
really put your foot forward and figure
this [ __ ] out cuz you know for us - it
wasn't laid out for us you know and I
think the cool thing is now that we're
in a position where we can actually tell
people so this isn't us telling it as if
a number one by the way I'm not a
bajillion heir either you know I'm
telling you things as I'm figuring this
out as well and it may or may not work
for you yeah everything is just a trial
and error right but then um I think when
people ask about finance like oh how do
you make more money how do you save
money how do you do all those things
there's a lot of information out there
there's so many ways to do it and
there's a lot of ways to do it you got
to figure out what works for you what
what your personality is like man if
you're a asian kid out there and i
already know this for a fact you got mom
and dad that tells you to live in the
house till you're like 25 [ __ ] living
that do it don't you dare [ __ ] move
out just so you could just smash a
random chick someone go get a [ __ ]
hotel stay in that house you would be so
surprised how much money you'll save
staying with your parents because
they're paying for toilet paper
[ __ ] toothpaste food unless you're
going out to eat all the time that ran
all these different costs that you're
not accruing for yourself you could take
that money and do something else with it
you know some people are like well
aren't you an adult and you move out my
[ __ ] you dude stay here and I'm gonna
suck on that tip - that titties drop
yeah and I'm gonna set myself up for the
future so I can help my parents out
later on - so while your parents are
healthy and if you do live in an
environment at home where your parents
like you and support you don't don't be
ashamed don't be embarrassed
take that help take that help I would
say work if you're at home and you're
not working and you're not doing [ __ ]
and that's problem and you're yeah
that's a big problem you got to work and
don't be too proud man like if you have
a college degree and you just can't get
a job do not be too proud work retail do
whatever you got to do because no matter
what you could climb up mmm like sure
you can you know work fast food but you
could you could become a manager like
you could climb up you know
there's you're not stuck at where you're
at it's a mentality of people thinking
that when they don't have anything at
all they still think things are beneath
them which doesn't make any sense you
you are in survival mode there is
nothing that's beneath you was beneath
you is the fact that if you don't have
cash and you're out on the street
sucking dick that might be [ __ ]
beneath you I had a friend of mine who
who so he originally wanted to go into
medical school right he found out that
it's not his [ __ ] but he still graduated
with a biology degree from Davis and
when we were talking to him he was still
living with his parents but he hadn't
worked for about a year
why because so check this [ __ ] out and
this is the thing that pissed me off and
he didn't like it when I said it to him
but he understood later on he got I go
why haven't you go I'm still looking for
a job I'm still I was like what do you
mean you're looking for a job what are
you looking for right now I was like
dude you you live at home but you're
still taking money from your parents
you're not really doing anything you're
just sitting around saying that you're
looking for a job it's been a [ __ ]
year what are you doing he goes Juan
looking for a job that's gonna pay me
about whatever I don't remember what the
price was but it was this amount of
money and I go okay that's cool but you
do know you could work a part-time job
right now have some money and cash
coming in while you still look for a job
he goes I I can't do that I'm like why
and this is what he said he goes to be
honest with you like I know this sounds
dumb but I think it's beneath me and I
said what what do you mean beneath Wow
he goes well I'm I'm college-educated
why should I have to work a part-time
job in like a subway or Wendy's or
whatever and I looked at him just pissed
I was like hold on a second what are you
even [ __ ] saying right he's an idiot
yeah you [ __ ] bum he wasted a whole
tire year when if he could have done
that part-time job he would have had
extra 15,000 in one year or some [ __ ]
exactly paying nothing his parents would
have still helped him out
so with that money that you could have
made because something is beneath you
which by the way is [ __ ] offensive
the people who are working those jobs
you're saying that just because you have
this little piece of paper
that you're better than the making money
they're not making any money at all
which I don't believe at all is unreal
there's people with no pieces of paper
that are very valuable human beings
exactly so there's that mentality that I
hope a lot of people don't have I don't
know if he was a very unique case
but it was so shocking when he said that
I wouldn't doubt it man because like
after a lot of us graduated there were a
couple of my friends who didn't want to
apply it like Sam's Club or Costco or
whatever and I'm like dude I needed a
job I went back to we're working 12
bucks an hour yeah and I was working at
the warehouse and I was working a
blue-collar job like moving boxes and
[ __ ] like that and I was like [ __ ] it
dude I don't I got a degree but I need a
job yeah and then I turned that twelve
dollar job into it you know $2,000 a
month with benefits
yeah so there is a way you know it's
still not that much money I mean like in
a minute now but you know back then it
was like it was hard man and all I gotta
say is there's a lot of information out
there but the information that you're
not gonna get and what you need is
self-control mmm so the information is
like how do you save an extra thousand
dollars how do you make you know how do
you make side income how do you make an
extra two hundred a month how do you
[ __ ] budget you'll find so much
information out there but the thing that
I can give to people is like you gotta
be aware that you're you're gonna go
through a lot of emotional turmoil that
you have to overcome that's the hardest
part about finance it's like an
addiction right in habit building it's
like it's the same thing as like
exercising if you're not used to doing
it it's hard as [ __ ] dieting if you're
not used to doing it it's hard as [ __ ]
right so if if you're the type of person
that gets Starbucks every [ __ ]
morning and you need your Starbucks it's
a it's a habit
you're you're you're spending seven
bucks every day but it's a habit you
have to do it it's hard as hell for them
to quit doing that mm-hmm or like if
they if they love shoes you know what I
mean like you knew what that was like
behind all the shoes like as soon as
they get to a check they've bonded shoes
or like so you have the problem with
spending or the opposite problem the
laziness not going out getting a job not
making money not doing anything just
sitting at home
like ruminating into thoughts [ __ ]
watching YouTube all day or whatever
like not doing jack [ __ ] right you have
these two opposite spectrums one is
spending too much one is not even making
anything yeah and people need to do the
bare basics make sure you have a job
make sure you budget [ __ ] these are
normal things it's not that hard
mm-hmm like if you fit if you put it
down on paper it's not that hard right
it's very simple it's just this that
right it's like make this much a month
spend this much a month now if you're
young this is not rocket science and it
only gets harder I get it if you're
listening right now and and and you have
you know some newborn kids you have a
mortgage you know you have sick parents
that you're taking care of you have you
know you just got laid off there's
people with problems out there right but
most young people don't yeah most young
people that I know it's just the
self-control issues there have a lot of
self-control issues yeah and then they
put a lot of pressure in their own heads
because they don't know what what's
what's really going on and this is some
stuff too just to bring it back once
again it's stuff that we deal with all
the time
mm-hmm self-control issues of stuff that
we have to really just kind of put
ourselves in check yeah like I said with
me it was spending foods many money on
food which is partially the reason why I
was [ __ ] fourth down oh my god dude I
was everyone's got their vices man we
all bought advice I don't have the shoe
buys but I had the [ __ ] eating vice
like a [ __ ] like I would eat dude
I would eat as if I was going on the
electric chair tomorrow you know I'm
like so we would go dude I don't know we
went it went out to eat we had our
[ __ ] table looked like we were about
to feed the King of Siam me and you I
know it was so ridiculous
we just wanted a bite of everything like
like a [ __ ] king that's how we were
and it was such a terrible thing to do
and it surpassed my original way of
living which was
how to save bending right because I got
accustomed to a certain lifestyle yeah
just it was I could have it so I'm gonna
have it which I never had that before so
it was that self control part was really
hard for me it was really hard yeah cuz
I used to look at the price for
everything everything oh how much is
that I can't buy that now and then what
it's like all of a sudden I could get
anything on the menu yeah and I could
get three things on the menu yeah I'm
I'm I want to taste that I want to taste
that I want to taste that you know but
it it gets a little too much it doesn't
make any sense man there was there was a
restaurant in Pasadena when I first
moved to LA I moved to South Pasadena
yeah there was a sushi restaurant called
mad city mad city I went there and I
only ate there on a special occasion
because I couldn't afford it
like I was making nothing so when I
first came to LA I was I was making
about $500 a month yeah my rent was 400
yeah that's how [ __ ] poor I was yeah
and then I had whatever that I saved up
because I sold all my Jordans I sold all
this other [ __ ] and that savings was
what I was surviving off that [ __ ] in
third four months I started doing show
stand-up shows and that started giving
me extra income but I would only eat at
Mozza D maybe once a month at most so
sometimes every other month and then I
remember when I started making good
money I went back to that restaurant and
I remember looking at that restaurant is
saying this is a treat I can't have this
all the time that was us wishing us and
gummy yeah and that became a weekly
thing that we ate like a [ __ ] Prince
of sudah anything I want do they loved
us dude that's for sure man and I dude I
would order okay I'm like oh we would
look at each other you guys want this
nasca you want this good let's get that
and at the end of the day there was so
much food I thought you know one month
we spend $8,000 on the car just for food
that's [ __ ] crazy because it was like
a decision between me and Bart we're
like you know everyone worked so hard
with our group you know like we would do
those 40 article late nights or whatever
I was like we were like the least we can
do is like not make people pay out of
their pocket for food right and let's go
on let's go like let's just get anything
to be lavish dude yeah let's get like
this let's laugh yeah let's do it man
and that was when we were doing really
well so it was like it didn't even make
a dent mm-hmm like it really didn't and
on top of that we were giving out those
bonuses and all that so then we didn't
scale back that kind of spending so that
was a big like doll yeah right but I
remember feeling that too is like man
going to these restaurants it was it was
like a special special treat yeah and I
never I never knew this freedom and once
you have that freedom it's very hard to
adjust back yeah which now I'm doing
though we used to get the [ __ ]
remember that Indo fried rice in the
pork chop deal at JJ's cafe or some [ __ ]
that used to be our special $3 and you
know what like yes six bucks and I don't
think people realize like how broke we
were when I first met them and they met
me we were both broke as [ __ ] I was
living on a thousand dollars a month
that was my that was my food car rent um
everything you know everything I needed
and I had about $100 or two every month
left over to put into my savings yeah
and my goal was basically after I paid
off my debt I paid myself $1,000 a month
to just live on and that was it dude I
was and people go you left on $1,000 a
month I'm like yes
it's possible yeah I did it for years
man I I people in my company were making
more than I was and that's what people
don't get is just like like you said you
were making what nine hundred bucks a
month five hundred five hundred a month
I'm living on five hundred miles I mean
on five hundred a month man and then I
and then he's that excess I had to dip
into my savings that I saved up to come
to LA yeah and I was living like that it
wasn't a problem especially cuz I was a
comic I didn't give a [ __ ] what I look
like dressed or nothing I was like I'm
supposed to be funny I I sell my [ __ ] by
words yeah that's how my doing
yeah and then so me and Bart we lived on
about a thousand bucks a month so so
thankfully you know Bart's mom was
financially intelligent you know cuz she
had that extra house in in Mario Parkin
and she didn't come from money man she's
saved and saved and saved and bought a
house right
and so like you know she let us use one
like the living room and then she gave
me cheap rent to stay in there and then
um oh and before that I actually lived
with Bart's dad I I rented a room from
him and and he ran it to me for like a
couple hundred bucks so that helped out
a lot but then I was paying normal
roommate prices like if you if you look
anywhere at the time I was paying the
same price as everybody else but it was
just comfortable living with his dad you
know
and then um yeah and all just literally
like we didn't spend nothing all the
money that we made from the company we
recycled it paid people out like just
kept buying equipment we did this for
five years man yeah and it wasn't till
2014 that we started to finally be able
to give ourselves a little bit more
money and in 15 16 17 is like when we
really went up but that's that's the
that's the case with I think a lot of
people don't realize this is our 11th
year yeah and it wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't like it happened overnight like
some of these other guys on YouTube you
know like well the platform was so
different dude I didn't you know until I
met you guys I really didn't know I
could make money on YouTube I was just
trying to be a big stand-up comedy
that's all I gave a [ __ ] about and I
actually was gonna quit YouTube after
the first year cuz I [ __ ] hated it it
we told you not to hey Bart and Joe were
the reason that told me not to quit
YouTube and they told me it was gonna be
profitable yes I got if you guys think
that I disappeared on YouTube for those
for the past year and a half and you're
like well where did he go let me tell
you something I was gonna disappear
after the first year yeah I think
lasting seven years is pretty [ __ ]
good alright cuz I didn't like number
one was like at the time being a
stand-up comic and being a youtuber was
a no-no people look down on me and mind
you when I came on to the YouTube space
I was like what 24 I was 24 I was doing
stand-up since I was 16 and so when I
remember this story
um well my personal story oh of course I
remember it but I did the stand-up show
and when they put me on that card and
the reason this actually sparked the
reason why I wanted to quit
because all I wanted to be was a huge
stand-up comic and then I told him that
I was a stand-up comic but they're like
and I know they did this [ __ ] on purpose
too they go
everybody was stand-up comic and the
next to my name they said youtuber and
they did it as a slight to me and I
looked at that [ __ ] and I was [ __ ]
infuriated like my blood [ __ ] boiled
now it's not a big deal but back then it
was a huge thing I remember it was yeah
like we weren't respected at all yeah
everybody would kind of consider us as
these like I don't know like wannabes or
whatever and I think everyone in our
generation didn't want the title
youtuber yeah now everybody wants to be
a loop on YouTube of it are you a
YouTube are you youtuber nah man there's
a shameful thing to be a youtuber people
just didn't understand what we were they
wanted you to be a comedic we wanted to
be comedian singers actors filmmakers we
didn't want to be youtubers yeah it was
totally [ __ ] different it was such a
weird space cuz I wanted P recognized as
a great stand-up comic and mind you I
wasn't that great but I did it for so
long I was still better and my personal
opinion at that time so for the set that
I went up to I was at the Ice House
Pasadena because my manager at the time
never saw me do stand him I was like yo
I've been doing stand-up I couldn't do
this [ __ ] and he goes well did you
prepare set I'll say I don't need to
prepare set it's a [ __ ] 10 minute slot
I'll [ __ ] fill that like nothing and
so I did it
yeah I did really well for at the time
and I remember because there's this dude
they remember this [ __ ] til this day
because in the back room there's a lot
of static comics who wanna who want to
do well yeah but sometimes it's a dick
measuring contest some people try to out
laughing out funny people in the
greenroom right exactly and those people
usually aren't the worst yeah that way
the people that are good they just sit
childers themselves and they do whatever
so this dude comes up to me and he goes
oh man so like you're the YouTube guy
right and right when he said that I was
already pissed mind you I had a bad
temper back in the day yeah
so I was like okay yeah so yeah I'm on
YouTube but he goes oh well you know
I've been doing stand-up for about you
know three or four years now so if you
need any pointers let me know I was
doing stand-up for eight so I looked at
him I was like hey that's cool man I've
been doing it for eight so go [ __ ] off
all right he goes up yeah [ __ ] bombs
not a single [ __ ] laugh yeah I go up
I did well I torqued that [ __ ] room
came back and I was like
sup now I just left it at that Wow you
know I [ __ ] hated that [ __ ] only
because and I'm not saying this to be
cocky it's just I paid my dues it was
she's just trying to get an ego trip on
you yeah he was trying to put me down
like I was offended because you have any
idea how hard it is to do stand-up and a
16 year old like that [ __ ] it was
difficult I paid my [ __ ] dudes you
don't get to talk to me like that and so
like for me I mean it was childish then
I probably wouldn't do it now as an
adult that would have done it a lot more
subtle but that was the the realm that
we came from in order to end up how we
are now yeah nobody knew that you could
actually make a [ __ ] ton of money on
YouTube at the time yeah it's I think
KevJumba I remember watching him on the
news and they were talking about how
they were using him as a tester for ads
and money and he was talking about how
he's paying his college through YouTube
yeah what the [ __ ] do you give money off
the [ __ ] you know and then I saw Shane
Dawson's videos and all this other stuff
and it just led to something else yeah
yeah we I mean I guess it just worked
out for us because it was for me was
like no turning back yeah I wasn't gonna
work that warehouse job or do anything
else I had to do this well but I think
that's kind of like going back to the
side hustle right and like doing things
that you care about and trying to make
that extra income and a lot of the times
when people feel like oh I can't do this
or I don't have time or whatever like
you got to check how you're feeling and
how you're thinking because it's usually
because you're just overthinking and
afraid yeah you know that's usually what
it is it's it's it's you don't know
where to start you don't know what to do
and there's too much pressure
there's too much anxiety or whatever but
just break it down into baby steps
what's the first thing you need to do do
you need to get a job you know like
people it's it's really that simple like
you're like I don't even know what to do
like I don't know where to start it's
like how about a job I know I mean I
can't do that right now literally like
that like oh [ __ ] man I can't pay my
bills I can't do this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know I'm like well the job that you're
doing right now is it making you that
much money what about another job I mean
you got 40 extra ow
that was only one part-time gig you
could do another job yeah they don't
even think about that it's like well I
I'm already doing 40 hours though it's
like okay no they were only doing like
20 hours oh [ __ ] okay well then he has a
lot of time yeah that's what I'm saying
it's like come on bro what else are you
doing for the rest of the time playing
[ __ ] dota and [ __ ]
seriously it's that simple but sometimes
they're like it's difficult because cuz
you get into this groove like you know
you know what that feels like when you
get into a groove of not working out or
or eating a certain way and then you let
yourself go and you're like oh look like
we all know the answer oh [ __ ] I got to
stop doing this I got to eat healthy
again I got a workout same thing with
Finance it's it's right under your nose
do you need to get a job do you need to
stop spending on shoes do you need to do
this like it's right there then the more
you start controlling that then you can
move on to the second stages of okay now
I already got a job now I got my budget
now I'm you know paying my bare
necessities now I want to save money now
strategize on that once you got that now
[ __ ] think about how to make more
money or think about a better job or a
better career or you know things like
that and it's all just baby steps when
you break it down into really small
achievable things like that your anxiety
will go away cuz you're not thinking of
a thousand other things just focus on
one little thing at a time that's that's
that's basically how I figured it all
out
so what you're saying a lot of people
just kind of jump steps and they're
thinking about plan D when they should
have just figured out finishing plan a B
and C first yeah and so they're thinking
about what do I have to invest into it's
like well let's let's let's slow down
for me money to invest first buddy well
what are you guys looking at these
magical bean and his Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup hold on buddy take those
buttons in your pocket don't count his
money yes so let's get a job in finances
first okay well you know what we've been
doing this for about an hour and 15
minutes I think that's a lot for you
guys to chew on for now um so if you
wanted to wrap this up what would you
say let's put into three big points well
what was the first one that we talked
about here the first one okay well the
first one
what [ __ ] I think it was control your
spending and budget control your
spending in write it to is like if you
if you don't have a job get a job make
more money so make or side hustle and
and you can do it in the form of like
outside like if you could teach
something if you can just Google right
now side hustles or whatever like uber
whatever extra income right and then if
you have debt pay off all the debt I
think that would be three if I could add
something okay so one would be look at
your budgets break it down to bare
necessities stop spending other [ __ ]
number to either increase your income by
by by trying to get a raise within your
workplace side hustles or whatever and
then three is pay off your debts if you
have debt and my strategy to pay off
debt is always pay off the highest
interest first yeah
now there's a lot of ways to do it but
if I could sum it up what I'll do is
I'll sign up for zero interest credit
cards with zero transaction fees Amex
has one called everyday the max is five
thousand dollars so you could transfer
from other cards to this America Express
card so if you have an American Express
to American Express it doesn't work so
like if you have a chase visa or
whatever transfer five thousand dollars
max to this card if you can accept it
for that much and then for 18 months or
so there's no interest you leave that
money in there
and so like my strategy would be let's
say you have a visa and you owe $10,000
right if you could if you could transfer
five thousand you leave that to the side
you start attacking that five thousand
inside your visa account and you start
deducting that pay that off pay that off
by 18 months hopefully that five
thousand dollars in the visa is taken
out taken care of and then you pay for
that chase I mean if you pay for the
AMEX card yeah now this is not advice
this is just something that I do if use
and that's fine yeah but there's a lot
of different methods there's people that
will do they'll pay the the smallest
loan first to build confidence so some
people out there have like
ten loans right and in one at the
highest loan they might be $100,000 and
a lowest loan is like a thousand dollars
right so what they'll do is they'll pay
the thousand dollar and then they'll go
up and in number that builds a lot of
confidence but my method is regardless
if it's a hundred thousand dollars or
twenty thousand dollars or five thousand
dollars I look for the highest interest
because they are charging the most okay
so I pay off that and then I pay off the
lower ones and then I use all kinds of
different strategies to maneuver my
money around but number three would be
pay off all your debts become debt free
and then we'll worry about all the other
[ __ ] like investing and all that later
okay because people tend to push that
aside all the time and they they move
they kind of jump that step because what
they realize the debt that you have is
actually money that you don't have yes
yeah and it's bleeding if you have
interest on that debt you're taking
money that means yeah they're they're
just charging you for owing money yeah
that's they're making money off of air
in time yeah so pay off that debt you
know well guys that concludes this
episode of genius brain podcast I am
David so and I am a jojje it's a cow a
baby
yes so remember we're over here if you
guys want specific advice if you want us
to go even more in-depth into this whole
financial thing let us know in the
comments if your muscle specific
questions yeah
specific would be great too because
right now we're just shooting in the
dark because there's so much information
to give out and you know who knows we
might actually bring somebody who is an
expert in this you know this podcast too
so don't be afraid to ask questions you
could check us out on cast box iTunes
Spotify a stitch or any kind of audio
platform that you could think of we're
on there and give us a thumbs up likes
go on that iTunes podcast and make sure
you give us a five star and just stay
interactive people I love you to death
you [ __ ] cute [ __ ] we will see you
next time
ba ba ba ba day